this is gonna be crazy yeah he might he  might catch it and jump over what's the  neighborhood Kitty on LeFrak City Queen  okay say one more driver little dollop  Raccoon City quit  go get that go get that  [Applause]  I love it  [Applause]  I gotta get up for this one get up  tea weights all in my way  [Music]  [Applause]  so easy little easy  what the plate sinks in slow motion this  was lucky there  yep that's that's an 8 right yeah that's  all I needed  yeah yeah Charlie you know the don'ts  he's looking so dead  [Music]  [Applause]  I thought a faculty go to the left yeah  oh yeah  14350 30 that's all you need he already  had the chocolate night  no pole vault there's your winner yeah  he deserves it - yeah everyone there's  your winner nine